una figura controversial que marcó la
argentina de los 90 a carlos menen se le
conoce tanto por haber llevado a
argentina al auge económico como por
haber tenido una vida plagada de
escándalos y acusaciones de corrupción
hijo de inmigrantes sirios y abogados de
carrera se incorporó al partido
peronista entre 1950 y 1960 siendo
gobernador de la rioja su provincia
natal fue arrestado tras el golpe
militar de 1976 y estuvo encarcelado
cinco años carismático orador se veía a
sí mismo como el sucesor de juan perón y
se vanagloriaba de no haber perdido
nunca una elección de un triunfador
total en el 73 en el 83 en el 87 en el
89 en el 95 cuando fui candidato
conocido a su llegada a la casa rosada
menem e enfrentó una argentina devorada
por la hiperinflación y con un alto
descontento social la apertura comercial
y las privatizaciones en masa fueron su
fórmula económica el modelo que
pretendía la igualdad peso-dólar
funcionó en su primer mandato y desató
una
época de euforia en el país pero su
segundo período iniciado en 1995 empezó
a desvelar desequilibrios que luego
condujeron de acuerdo a analistas a la
crisis del corralito en 2001 puso
argentina en el escenario internacional
atrajo la inversión extranjera y envió
tropas a la guerra del golfo y a bosnia
en su apogeo el extravagante presidente
invitó a su residencia a los rolling
stones y protagonizó escándalos
sensacionalistas dejó el cargo acusado
de corrupción y de vender ilegalmente
armas a croacia y ecuador por lo que fue
absuelto diez años después con órdenes
de arresto en su contra permaneció en
autoexilio varios años en chile en 2005
regresó al país y fue elegido senador
durante sus últimos años fue acusado de
obstrucción a la primera investigación
sobre el atentado contra la mutual judía
amia en 1994 caso por el que fue
finalmente absuelto
actualmente estaba procesado por estrago
doloso en el caso de la explosión de una
fábrica militar en 1995 que dejó siete
muertos el juicio que fue
por su estado de salud estaba previsto
para el 24 de febrero